all right we are now live for the next
philosophy pop-up we do two of these
each month one on YouTube live and one
on Facebook live well I'm of course on
my youtube channel which year you're
saying it on now if you're if you're
here and the Facebook live on my page
all you gotta do is type in Gregory B
Sadler and it'll come right up so today
while we're waiting for viewers to come
in let me just tell you about about I
wanted to do something for January in a
classic philosophical idea Plato's
allegory of the cave a sequence of
videos on heidegger's reinterpretation
of it in his his little essay marks
called Plato's doctrine of truth very
interesting stuff but kind of abstract
kind of tricky if you don't know
Heidegger his work all that well
although hopefully they adequately
adequately enough in the videos I don't
want to talk so much about how I figure
today and I'm more interested in
thinking about the plain old allegory of
the cave as Plato tells it and I wanted
to actually start out by talking about
an experience that I had this week which
is an all too often experience for
myself and I would imagine perhaps for
viewers as well and it's something that
is happening in contemporary life it
happened you know 50 60 years ago except
in certain areas where they have lots
and lots of money I'll just sort of tell
the story then we'll talk about how it
relates to Plato's allegory the cave so
I I want to admit this week and as usual
you know you've got a waiting room and
waiting rooms are you know kind of nice
these days at least in a lot of places
just to be and they have you know the
magazines that are sitting there
oftentimes the doctor or doctors will
have subscriptions to
time and Sports Illustrated and you know
you can page through them and and all
that what you're waiting I usually bring
a book myself because you know I'm
trying to get some some work done
ubiquitous features of offices these
days that I cannot stand is that there's
always a TV over in the corner such a
way that you cannot if you're looking
around not see it because they set it up
for optimal viewing and it's usually
blaring ring it's not blaring like you
know cultural programming or something
like that no it's always on some some
talk-show and you know some of the most
banal talk shows where it's just Chiti
Chiti chatter chatter you know like like
the view or or you know some local show
like that and you know it's always like
feature of this and feature on that and
you know I you know I watch that on
there and I'm like likes this or it's on
a cooking show or it's on some other
kind of reality show like you know last
the one that I went to they're having
some cooking contest Bobby Flay was in
it
I don't know what it was about but they
are doing recipes I think it had to do
the mushrooms or some nonsense like that
and it makes it impossible to read
really interesting I looked around the
room because I again I was like well who
watches this stuff you know who's in it
and I noticed there about you know five
six people in the waiting room
almost none who is this crap here for
and and why I mean is it for the
receptionist's who are checking yes in
I'm sure I'm using the wrong word for
the people who try there's probably some
terminology and I don't mean to offend
anybody but is it so that they can
listen to something all day long I mean
that would drive me nuts and when I was
at Lakeland College which is now
Lakeland University this is over 20
years ago this is back in the early 90s
I remember when they put a TV in the
library and I don't think brackets
hanging there this is before flat
screens and I was like this is a
terrible idea
librarians were like no no because we
can you know put the channel with
announcements on it
and then when people come up they can
see it and I was like Dan what student
workers are like that's gonna be tuned
to some show you know as soon as your
backs are turned and of course that was
the case and it happened so often that
eventually they just think they quit
fighting it and they were just have a
show on so you're sitting there in the
library
you know sporting event or as playing
along with commercials and you're like
this is supposed to be a place to read
quiet place what the hell's going on
here right now how does this connect
with Plato's allegory of the cave well
you know in Plato's allegory of the cave
story that's being told about these
peoples right and I can only look at a
wall or you know in our time a screen
and and they see shadow figures playing
on the fire behind them and people are
working with puppets you know and you
know this this would have taken a lot
out of work in ancient times but if you
think about our contemporary what does
it take to create a web series that's
going to be streaming on Netflix and
people can just sit there and watch you
know for hours on end binge watch
why does shows love reality series
because they're cheap to produce and you
know they're not that that difficult
they're not that
watch them while they're doing other
stuff that isn't intellectually
demanding but you know what's going on
here is we're being presented in the
cave with that simile at best of reality
and something that has been manipulated
and is being presented here's what
Plato's problem is it's being presented
to us as if that is a depiction of
reality a faithful depiction and that
depiction becomes taken as self and and
he talks about the people in the cave
arguing with each other fighting with
each other they're saying that you know
son is better at predicting what's going
on that person is you know better at
understanding what's happening things
are are you know what's what's taking
place in the story and it's really quite
quite interesting ooh
think about the implications you know we
have these people that engage in all
this media analysis trying to tell us
about what's you know what's going on
what we should be thinking about what
happened on Twitter you know what we
should think about what what somebody
else is saying all all of these sorts of
issues so you know oftentimes in caves
within caves and you know what'swhat's
the liberation from the cave this is
where the real real question comes in
how do you get out of the cave do you
can you like break the chains yourself
do you need somebody else to come in and
pull you out does it have to have maybe
some random event that gets you you know
the cave or or something like that
does philosophy play a role Plato
thought that philosophy played an
important role in getting us out of the
cave but that you know when the person
comes back into the cave and they're
talking about like having seen the real
things other people like what the hell
is this guy talking about I mean look at
him he can't even like identify what's
happening on the wall anymore
yeah and he's talking about like a world
of Bob and all this guy's dangerous
so you know it's been used as a like
allegories are Christmas and I think
it's even more important in our own time
at least to introduce people to it I
don't to say that there's one definitive
you know proper conception of the cave
and all the others are bunk or anything
like that I think that would be like a
contest within the cave but I do think
that it's it's something worth looking
at so I see we've already got a lot of
questions here some of which are kind of
off topic and some of which are on topic
but I'm gonna run through them people
are starting out with greetings and I'm
not sure what's I mean seem to be
missing like there's a big blank space
here but I'll just start where I see
things so 19 blue 51 asks this important
question can someone be freed from the
chains and find their way or the way out
of the cave without the guidance of
another just play two addresses yeah he
doesn't address this is the philosophers
genuine philosophers not people who are
portraying the poses philosophers who
would be in his times Sophists but in
our time would probably be a lot of the
academic philosophers and some of the
people who are just sort of you know
little Glaucus as a way to make money or
something like that self-help you know
doing the thin veneer stoicism is is
getting a lot of it at these days
because it's quite popular so you get
these these people that are doing a
little bit of gussied up you know
business theory and then they like to
picture it with a bit of stoicism and
they say yeah this is you know ha anyway
can you be freed from the chains without
by you know without somebody else
helping you um you know in the allegory
no imagine that you were you know like
let's say the chains just came loose how
would you know to go up you know you've
only been here that your entire life how
would you know what to do unless there
was something in the stories that you're
seeing on the screen that's a how hinted
at it and gave you something for it
right
Dennis writes Nietzsche escape from the
cave he saw how things really were in
all camps along that nature the
philosopher-king
possible I would say that you know he
Chester certainly somebody worth
studying but but I that I I drew on him
I think if I were gonna say who's got
the best view on life I don't know that
I would pick him um it's greetings from
Columbia I'm currently reading the
Republic just got to book seven it's
gonna be perfect William he's pulling a
David Foster Wallace no idea what that
would possibly mean yeah you know I've
read a few of his essays not
particularly impressed gonna say here's
a kind of silly question from minute
aureus is this a channel about the glory
of man caves I don't have a man cave
I've been in some but I live in an
apartment in downtown Milwaukee so we
don't we don't really do any any sort of
thing like that all right so let's let's
take some some some other real questions
get a scroll up a bit here we go so mark
actually point something out good here
about the cave that that it keeps people
from having to face each other everybody
in the the allegory of the cave is
facing forward so imagines something
like a movie theater now that raises
certain problems like you know what
happens when they eat you know or how do
they go to the bathroom or so they laid
down to go to sleep or how do they
reproduce and that sort of thing but we
might we might talk about those those
sorts of things all right so this I
guess would be I would pronounce it
asked do you think atheists are those
philosophers who
the cave really atheists are their own
caves I think there's many different
kinds of caves you know so I is that the
atheists have actually got it right may
not be the case but let's say that they
did you'd have to look at the important
of the atheists a lot of atheists come
from a very you know state and so they
might be you know sort of a
fundamentalist or or any angelic goal or
something like that at some sort of
biblical literalist you know in terms of
Christianity and what happens to them
when they become an atheist they turn
into a just as much of a crusader as
they were before and in sort of
unselfconscious ways that that turn a
lot of people off so no I think
intrinsic to atheism that would amount
to getting out of the cave as a matter
of fact in in some atheistic societies
maybe taking a theistic standpoint it
might be a way out of the cave right
forget the name of that polish filmmaker
who did the red-white-blue trilogy but
he did a really interesting sequence on
the Ten Commandments back when it was
still under the Soviet occupation well
worth taking a look at for sort of light
hand on that
Seth Perry
you ever do Street epistemology I don't
know what it is
I've heard it people use it as a
buzzword but it strikes me as something
that might be like a you know fan so I
can't say oh there have to it or not um
19 blue if learning is recollection do
all souls base from which to recollect
so in Plato at least some knowledge is
recollection right I mean knowing that
water is wet sure that's not coming from
recollection that's that's experiential
you know knowing mathematics that is
this you know knowledge is recollection
and it's awakened in us and and that
sort of thing the way that he presents
it is yeah we wouldn't all have the same
or relying on in the Phaedrus he gives a
sort of account of how this takes place
you know when when you get to see the
forms but it's never really discussed in
detail any the written works that we
have by Plato precisely how oh well this
is supposed to happen that we have to
you know we shouldn't interpret Plato
ever is claiming that all knowledge of
all things is always right a collection
because then just hear it there's gonna
be there's gonna be some stuff that that
is a priori knowledge and notice too
that it's not something that you get
like boom you know it requires dialectic
it requires working through things it
requires sometimes changing one's
character to be able to access that
Pushkin writes in the Republic Socrates
claims it's never just to harm anyone
because harm will make the harm look
less just who I think that so there's
two things to say two three so one is
just harming a person make them less
just no not necessarily in some cases it
does in some cases it doesn't this is an
issue in the philosophy of punishment
second is does Socrates say that at some
point yes is that actually Socrates he's
full position no and it's not Plato's
whole position either because just read
the gorgeous and you'll see that
punishment is a way of getting people to
- way to improve them in some ok this is
I think that nobody should ever harm
anyone it depends on what you you you
count as term in part that there are
kids where we should punish and I think
there's cases where we should fight in
cases like that so yeah
Heidegger renounced the Platonic idea
still have an interest objective logos
that allows for social meaning I don't
know how can this Aristotle I mean to
buy into Plato's forms to have some sort
of any logos here speak each right
Aristotle says human beings have logos
and that gives us not only you know
reasoning but also the capacity for
communication and not just communication
about you know like hey the the rock is
gonna fall on your head but
communication about moral values and
Aristotle already there calls that he's
sharing at Koinonia so the Platonic
ideas or say that you know if you don't
have to renounce them you can just say I
think way understand anything's and you
don't lose interest subjectivity as a
result um ok do this idea interesting is
it possible that outside the cave is
inside another cave imagine or the
deepest level of Inception movie you go
up here still deep in the same set up
yeah there's a lot of movies I
particularly like the 13th floor which
has not been you know didn't get
option but the interesting one because
in the 13th floor that one has to do
less with dreams and it has to do more
with the conception of reality and in
its in this world which we take to be
the world that that is real a computer
company has created a alternate you know
reality it's led job in that the the at
least some of the people within that
that that reality we have figured out
that they are in something well like
that's like the platonic thing they
figured out that they're in a cave and
there's a greater world of bog well it
turns out that this world this greater
world above is yet another VR thing of
the real world which is like in you know
the two thousand things
yeah the characters who's been
investigating things is you could say
you're you're in the what's right you're
full thing that attains consciousness
you can go up to the next level and
start doing things there so yeah I mean
we have all sorts of really interesting
things along these lines you know and
and you don't mean virtual reality or
stuff like that to do it you know more
haze has some stories that are like that
the circular ruins for example oh and
yeah I mean the question that you want
to ask is well how would you know that
you're outside of the cave altogether
right um let me scroll up
yeah Alejandra I've heard about David
fought David Foster Wallace's Infinite
Jest never read it though only read this
is water for my apology classes yes it's
either people were all all you know a
gag about him for a long time but you
know I'm not her remember you know I
spend so much time reading primary texts
and mostly you know ancient medieval
early modern some some late modern stuff
I don't have much time for reading sort
of staying on top of the culture that as
you know maybe a I have a duty to I
don't know we kind of specialize a bit
and so so a lot of a lot of the stuff
that the you know the people read and
talk about they're not they're not very
good reference points for me you know
unfortunately let's see the Third's vie
again
different to the idea of a Sufi but an
idea you have a Sufi is that maybe I'll
I'll I'll talk about that but D in like
an idea that a Sufi has or I don't
really know so okay
minutes parts are there in the allegory
well that's pretty straightforward so
there's a cave right and you've got at
the wall and and the shadows aren't
aren't real they're in fact even less
real than the people who are watching
well as themselves then you got the
people behind them with the puppets that
are actually casting shadows and the
fire so that's that's real in the cave
and in some respect just more real than
the shadows right because those are the
effect of that cause then you go
upstairs and in plane first the person
who's coming out of the cave they have
to acclimate their eyes to the light and
so they I'm not really sure why because
they have to like look at things in
water rather than looking directly at
them and so that's another love Oh
reflections of real things right even
though the puppets and marionettes are
kind of copies of the real things above
then you got the real things they may be
the absolute highest level is looking at
the thing that illuminates and gives
rise to all of these things which is the
Sun so I guess you could say have five
levels and the human I mean here's
what's really interesting about the
allegory that came at Plato doesn't talk
about it all that they're you know
rising through almost and and you know
making sense of them now the Sun is you
know in some respect greater than human
beings but if you're in the higher if
you if you get into the upper world
I actually figure out what a human being
is - I suppose right so that's that's a
cool question so so six asks what
another meaning how would a philosopher
know that he got out of the cave you'd
have to have some sort of frame of
reference yeah and so know that there
aren't further caves beyond I think you
know if there's there's sort of an
inkling that there may be you could have
something else and you can conceptualize
it
how do we get to that more real thing
and this is one of the issues with with
the allegory right this is where we were
starting running into its limitations no
in the allegory because some guy comes
down and pulls you out and says hey look
around sort of like in the matrix right
you've got Morpheus and neo and you know
this whole interesting story being
played you get this and so many other
things to you right where oh my gosh
look we we've been to see and and you
know I suppose there would probably be
some sort of pragmatic
test you know is this good enough is
this do I feel like this is enough
reality for me compared to the lesser
reality that that I for
the cave and you start telling people
about this they're gonna be like you're
nuts buddy look this is great um so you
know I think you'd have to like a
support group maybe of people who were
also out of the cave right 19 blue has a
question here about Asian and
commercialisation of stoic philosophy
can it be problematic to co-opt an idea
from a larger philosophical system and
use it as a life at like yeah yeah I
mean problematic million different
things right but usually we were using
it as kind of a shorthand for in doing
that or its illicit and so here's this
is something I've actually given a lot
of claw to you know I'm gonna system
today I work with the stoic fellowship
you know so I'm kind of involved in the
moderate movement so if as strictly
speaking stoic so there's a lot of
people trying to market product make
money and come all at best stoicism
light right and it's to be sure there's
people doing that with Plato with other
things as well now is it is it wrong for
them to be doing that if it if it gets
in the way of people who genuinely want
to know something about stoicism being
able to to study the real 30 yes but
that's not the case I mean if you want
to read stoic text they're available
online you know there's lots and lots of
resources it who wants to learn about
stoicism I think you know there's
there's really almost nothing impeding
them so they want to be content with you
know reading popularizing books that are
not that are not particularly good so we
know what would be examples of books
that are are
well some of the the people who I work
with you know Massimo's
wanna be a stoic that's a good book I
just finished reading Chuck Chopra
Connie's freedom before too long and
although I disagree with him about you
know his approach to stoicism is you
know very simple philosophy I think it's
plenties he's got it I think his book is
good and I think you could learn quite a
bit from from reading that then there's
a little literature where it's like wow
I'm gonna capitalize on it and you know
you could say well what about the poor
people who don't know any better and
they see that this is bestseller well
you know I'm doing any research that's
their own problem you know and I do
think that the the stuff that kind of
towards the the real stuff now I know
there's others in the the movement that
are more pessimistic about this and very
worried about the sort of Gresham's law
right bad money drives out good money
and I guess the metaphor there would be
counterfeit versus you know real about
it as they are I think that we don't
want to endorse this stuff we don't want
to be sending the wrong example those
those who actually do know something
whether it be stoicism or about me chair
existentialism or whatever we don't want
to be like lending you know our
imprimatur to it need to be like we can
go after them if we want we could say
there's a bad book this is this is no
good you know or this is this this you
know inner workshop that's being sold as
you know being founded in stoicism this
really is not stoic stuff and I think we
do have a obligation let me see you know
stoicism or Platonism or whatever beings
used for very narrow ads commercial ends
primarily it's like you know being
co-opted by these people are these
people say something about it and we are
you know so so I think that's that's
that's important pappa meant to ask too
many people know they're in the cave
well in the allegory no that's why
they're they're still down there because
if they knew they probably would say
screw this let's get the hell out of
here right in the applications that I've
seen people make of it usually it's
about something where the masses don't
know and maybe the elites are pulling
the strings behind and the elites may
not even know that there is an outside
of the cave they just think well look
somebody's got to be making the images
so it may as well be us controlling all
right so Nate
has how does reaching as it has in many
a the other dialogues relate to exiting
the cave and finding an essential truth
in the allegory so opera is when you you
reach a state where you can't you can't
progress any forward and this happens in
you know some of the earlier dialogues
you know are the early dialogues when
you know they try to reach a definition
and they they find out that none of the
definitions you know whether it's piety
courage temperance none of them actually
work there's also the like person coming
in this is disgusting me know where they
think that they know some thing and they
talk with Socrates for a short time and
then they realize they have no idea what
the hell they're talking about they
can't explain it in coherent ways
there's you know internal contradictions
and what they're saying and they're like
well what's going on and they talk about
this is like being stung by a stingray
paralyzes you right so can that play a
role yeah that definitely in getting out
of the cave it's it's a preparatory
thing it gets you ready to be able to
like think and listen and so I think
it's it's it's got a point to it but
it's not an absolutely necessary thing
there's some people you know if you read
the rest of the Republic right there are
some people who are naturally inclined
towards and desire learning and you may
not have to stingray them right or some
of them may be you might have to is it
all depends like sort of a toolkit right
so John Jones right there's no escaping
the cave the best you can do is to know
that you are in the cave so that's
that's the view I think probably of the
people who are doing the puppets behind
all right get the key patients to go up
in the riddle we're all there something
like that you know we don't actually
know much about them but we could we can
you know speculate and that's a nice
thing with platonic dialogues is we
generally have to go beyond that
like Oh meat out of it Giovanni asks a
question like totally off topic here you
familiar with planting on it so what do
you make of his critique of classical
foundationalism in connection with Nick
and Cheyenne's critique of the same
thing uh I haven't read him for years
not particularly interested in him
veggies he him speak I you know I'm not
particularly interested in in analytic
philosophy in general so I don't
remember his critique of classical
foundationalism quite frankly I mean
Rick and I Heinz know okay that that's
interesting you know languages it's used
and we're never gonna really get to you
know some sort of bedrock thing where
where we can we can found a track I
don't remember if that's connected with
what planting is doing or not but so I I
don't have much to say about that
oh here's a really interesting question
who are some renowned philosophers you
completely disagree with so for if we're
being literal completely disagree with
nobody because there's almost always
gonna be something
at least we agree about this so let's
let's make it a little bit less rigorous
and say
generally disagree with quite frequently
people ask me about how come you're not
doing videos on Spinoza and I'm always
like well you know yeah but I'm not a
big fan Spinoza I don't believe that
everything is just one one substance and
it's known through its these two
attributes out of you know that and that
the word is modes and thing is label you
know ma quite frankly I don't buy into
the Platonic theory of the form so I
think I think there's some serie I'm
really fascinated by it but I really
disagree with that I'm also equally
fascinated with Hobbes political
philosophy although I disagree with it
but I have many accounts and I think
that dangers in modern life and I've
written about this in you know academic
articles is of Hobbes's it's becoming
sure than the de facto who else I mean I
disagree with Hegel on history having
ended and and dialectical shapes of
consciousness fitting in with each other
you know I'm gonna go on and on there's
there's there's I'm usually more
interested in what I'm taking from a
philosopher than what I'm criticizing in
a philosopher myself so oh wow here's an
interesting question I just lost it
because the thing suddenly is grown so
Philip asked what have you put an oculus
rift on a newborn baby and never took it
off for the rest of its life I guess it
would just be getting fed that visual
information ever suspect that there was
something else going on I guess it would
depend on what it's getting through its
other channel it's right
[Music]
although the oculus rift is going to be
hearing - right I
it would be stuck right unless somebody
pro-grade our that they're in hey you're
being you're being deceived
so yeah so mark yes I had a dream where
I dreamt the dreamer who dreams reality
that's an aneurysm IRA but after reading
Bohr Hayes this circular reference
destroys the hierarchy and normativity
of the forms I'm not sure that the forms
have there I mean levels right of
reality and or you could have different
you know different realities and if you
believe the concept of the forms you
know there's archetypes there why would
they just run through all of them you
know and
and sort of also the only one also how
does one inspire others to leave behind
the Cape so is you know this is talked
about in plato's restricts ticking
there's two levels to the story there's
the actual like came that the people are
in and there you need some somebody else
to come in and help you out and then you
know you go back down in and it's gonna
be difficult to get people to buy into
your store or brilliant
criminal inspiring them to leave the
cave you don't inspire them you drag
them up into the light now Plato talks
about this own story and in terms of
what philosophy does so philosophy to
the forms but if it's a long difficult
process and oftentimes we do have to
kind of drag people up into it and it's
it's not for the at a certain thinking
and you might say take ownership you
know or exercise some agency on their
own part and say I think I want to
continue my studies and you know get
further out of the cave then how do you
inspire people in Plato's point of view
everybody not everybody is gonna be
suited for that but those who have you
could say the potential for it or that
that doctrine of recollection comes in
and helps I think when we feel this this
sense of also a kind of affinity or like
I want to know more about this I don't
fully understand this but I want to get
my my head around as we say we're drawn
by what Plato talks about in the
symposium is platonic arrows in do
Thomas each for for understanding you
know what we come to grasp as this is
really reality not just the stuff that
I've been how would you inspire others I
think it would have to be in a very at
first what kind of roundabout way it's
not going to be well I'm gonna give you
a textbook and here you go this is the
textbook for getting out of the cave it
wouldn't work like that you know it's
going to be all the is contingent
and with each other I mean if I think
about how I got into studying different
figures in philosophy it was always very
you know happens tense
reading reading this and then there was
a reference to something I was like
maybe I'll go check out that book you
know or sometimes it was you know a
person who I actually admired somebody
and recommended it and I was like well
okay since they recommend it and I think
they're not full of crap like everybody
else I'll go check it out
you know so um em x.25 i've escaping
from the cave is the same as meeting the
one so the only way out of the cave
isn't by using reason but only possible
by the ecstasy like latinas has said or
by a meditative experience question mark
there's an assertion right escaping from
the cave is not the same thing as
meeting the one in Plato's allegory so
the one that would correspond to you
know what Platina is talking about would
be the Sun that you meet and that's
outside of the cave you're right but so
are all the other things that you're
seeing you could say that maybe the last
step in the journey is is a something
through ecstasy or meditative experience
but I mean Platonism by itself here's
the thing reasoning for a plate mist is
not something that's not meditative play
major part of that so if you're
contrasting a very abstract sense of
reasoning that per Harry and you'd have
to have something that's that's going
beyond that but that's not the way play
don't use the word reason so yeah I
comparing Plato's allegory of the matrix
story where does skepticism really stop
we can surely go on doubting everything
he even the Sun level the skepticism
never stop yeah in the fact that you can
doubt something doesn't mean that you
have good grounds to doubt it I'm kept
achill thing that you look at winds up
reconstructing the world whether it's
sex disappear aquellas or Descartes or
humor whoever talks about this as well
Charles purse the great American
philosopher who originally made the term
pragmatism then had it stolen from him
by William Jay and his philosophy of
pragmatism you know in the matrix story
it's a lot simpler cuz and you know we
see that because it's it's an action
movie and all this sort of stuff big war
those scary tentacle things will get you
I mean and you could say well in where
there's like he meets with the architect
there I mean they're there or outside
and inside the matrix in a certain sense
you watch that stuff to really say that
much about it but you know no I mean
it's good this isn't missing something
to engage it just for its own sake right
let's scroll down some more mark offer
escape from relativism and confusion and
private in communicable meanings forms
are the source of both being an
intelligibility instead of illusion and
confusion truth and objectivity third
one way to do that Aristotle has another
way Stoics have another way you know
there's many different by both of ism
you know I don't think platonic forms
were the only way to go oh
minotaurs every time I see a movie at
the theater I think of the allegory oh
yeah the screen the projector light the
actors oh [ __ ] oh oh this is a good
point well oceans from a scripted story
yeah
real emotions not just manufactured
emotions we have real responses we are
in some sense more real than those those
stories that part of what provokes the
emotions for us you think about what is
it that provokes our different emotions
so you can say well it's the plot you
know the things that people are saying
that's true music plays a huge role in
it as well you know itself knew about
because he writes about this in the
Republic and somewhere else as well
different modes induce different
different moods you know this is
associated with getting angry and
aggressive you know I think it's the
phrygian move would you know you don't
want to be there because it gets people
too relaxed but that plays a role and
then you know there's a kind of that big
element there too
so I'm the actors are really great at
projecting emotion others we say we're
not not very believable not very good
right those responses in a sense they're
manufactured right but they are real
responses that were happy yeah an entry
that this puzzle lot of philosophers
think about horror movies for example we
see as in horror movies being in real
life should terrify the crap out of us
or you know steal us up for for fighting
or something like that you know I think
horror fans that the horror horror
comedy like you know ash vs. Evil Dead
which is something that I particularly
like oh there's another one with Stan
stand against evil right that
if we're seeing no horrible zombie is or
stuff like that that should scare the
hell out of us and yet we're like ah ha
ha ha ha
look at this funny where the great so um
one of the things that these these
philosophers say so how can we see these
things to picked it on the stage that
that are objectively you know and yet we
don't you know this goes all the way
back to Aristotle but then gets
discussed a lot in in the like the early
modern to the late modern period testing
idea so six why would I want to get out
of the cave taking the blue pill oh why
do you think the consequences are
staying in the cave and leaving the cave
after all neo died in the end well I
mean that's one story all right so so uh
a story watch the 13th floor or dark
City or or any other game any of these
others that play with similar sorts of
ideas and then then maybe generalize
from those we could do that but this is
a also an age-old problem two poses this
problem very interestingly in his
patients but all space with Princess
Elizabeth is it better for us to do feel
okay and be deceived
you know maybe enjoy things a bit or or
is it better for us to actually know the
truth it can be painful really
fundamental question isn't it and I
think a lot a lot of people do not just
you know in plato's time in our time but
you know historically cross-culturally I
think more people would take the blue
pill given the option but those people
finish back into the matrix so yeah um
let's see Daniel writes oh there's a
thing going on here about dialectic
again discussed in in in the Republic
you know book six is where you want to
go for that POW cake maybe I'm not sure
how to read read that name a friend had
mentioned that the allegory the glue
differently or something around those
words is that so and how yeah I think
it's I think it's good it's probably not
the only metaphor you'd you know
education or getting you know dealing
with deception or things like that but
it's a good one it's it's it's sort of a
touchstone for the a nice common
vocabulary for thinking about these
these sorts things it's a good starting
point look it's just a part of Plato's
Republic it's part of book seven but
it's not at the whole of book 7 lb
writes I'm not interested in feminism er
II enduring two women specifically but
considering the stigma of inferiority
just see women navigating philosophy
beyond exploring Sophie's world so I've
never read Sophie's world I think I
thought those of like philosophy but for
children understood but I don't know um
so Oh philosophy I had kind of a unusual
experience you know I keep seeing all
this stuff about like iron man's and all
that that hasn't been my experience most
play this is that I've worked or where I
did my my stuff you know we had a lot of
women graduate students and and quite a
few women professors where I went to
cool Southern Illinois University I
worked under one oh yeah I said I worked
under several Donna Summer field -
unfortunately died of cancer great
Vidkun Stein style puller I started out
writing my master's thesis under her two
classes with her
I learned my my my Greek in part from
man and in part from women you know and
you know this is right Todd again you
know I didn't chairs who were women and
I know that whenever I apply for a
philosophy job there's always like
parties are especially encouraged to
apply so it's not as difficult to get a
position in flaw because there is this
gender and been out I do understand that
in some places very hostile environments
I just haven't been in those those
places for the most part so you know I'm
receptive to it but I uh I don't I don't
I don't know enough about it to I I know
I that said what about women and
philosophy there's plenty of it you know
there's plenty of women who really
deserve a role in the philosophical
canon who don't get taught or talked
about or recited somebody who i do a
good bit of work that was mary
wollstonecraft
you know she is just as you know
brilliant as so who she's a critic of
works deserved to be read and discussed
and you know that she's left out one of
the sort of history of morale except
when we get to like women's ideas you
know she's really within the manger and
she theorized about the relationship
between men and women in ways that I
think are very important and about
culture and politics and education you
know
I part and making sure that that when
I'm teaching classes or when I'm doing
my presentations that that I am
including you know great women thinkers
because there's plenty of them out there
you just got to do the work to actually
read them and I think that that plays a
role so I think some of this too is
gonna take several generations
you know I am willing to bet that by the
time that I died sort of old boys
network BS that's been going on in some
places for a long time be put to rest
and and I think it deserves to be put to
rest because you know I don't I don't
like discrimination of that authority
you know this Plato in the Republic
talks I was just talking about this with
another student played it so he you know
when he divides up these classes you
know the the thinkers and rulers the
warrior class everybody else he says you
know should women be fighting with men
and a lot of people in his time would
say no women are clearly you know figure
in that respect and Plato says wow you
really don't know women do you just as
fierce as some men and there's plenty of
men who don't have a loss
Domenic for fighting we go with the
distinction that matters what your what
your temperament is rather than the
distinction that doesn't matter what you
know what generals you're born with we
can say something similar about you know
the philosophical field or or other
fields so yeah
let's scroll down a bit to every time
and I click on this or questions okay
design Balan what do you think about
Plato's Republic idea of the relation
between the family and the community
entity and Hegel's idea I stayed in the
phenomenology I mean in Plato's ideal
Republic you don't really have much of a
family there they're kind of trying this
is Aristotle's criticism you try
and it turned a big family and that's
not a really great idea you do need to
have this sort of you know separate but
Aris owes another year someone's right
about that in in the relationship
between the family in the state and the
phenomenology we're talking about one
particular section which is early on in
spirit portion worked a very long hard a
portion of the work can we relate that
to at Plato saying I mean if Plato's
Republic was there and you wouldn't be
able to have that that developed but
there's that much of a connection um
there's an interesting question from
Pacino Plato believed from the leave to
the rebirth of souls do you think souls
are gendered what would be different
philosophers opinion of this so yeah if
you have a reincarnation going on and
how could you have gendered souls I mean
it doesn't work that way in religion is
that that have reincarnation okay
typically goes like this well if you're
born as a man that must be a signer you
did something right if you're born as a
woman that's a sign you did something
wrong which I you know I mean like if
you're born into an animal well you must
have been doing something wrong so let's
beat the hell out of here or treat you
bad you know so so we see that in in
places we do believe in reincarnation
sometimes you know you would think
they'd be like oh those poor bastards
they're like me but they're stuck any
animal else instead sometimes they're
worse than animals
it's like if we would follow Plato's
idea then Souls really wouldn't wouldn't
have gender the gender is something that
points to the body so you know and you
do see you know a lot of son Socrates
part Plato having him say this there's a
lot of like well you know some things
some of these distinctions don't matter
so much
Sean asks will you ever talk about
economic philosophy such as Adam Smith
why'd you talk about economic philosophy
in some of my videos and when I talk
about Smith sure you know one of the
things that eventually down the line
I've committed to doing is you know once
they reach a certain level of support
and on patreon do an entire sequence on
on social and political philosophy which
would include a lot of economic thinkers
but actually you have the well you know
the continuing financial resources to do
that you know I I don't I don't have a
university supporting me or the
government supporting me it's uh um you
know my tutorial sessions or
philosophical counseling or consulting
or
you know book sales or stuff like that
or you're speaking on the one hand and
then patreon people crowdfunding me and
supporting the work that I do so once I
reach a certain level that frees me up
to be able to do that sort of thing so
if you're interested in that you want to
look at the actually I should probably
put this thing that I owed it to put in
there at the end out patreon so I'll put
that in the text thing all right let me
go down Elric the impaler that's innate
whatever I'm deeply meditating my
neighbors freak out and begin to make
noises Wow that would be an impediment
they don't know that you're meditating
maybe don't tell them
Jacob writes in my class the professor
made the case we should ignore pretty
much everything he in speech for its
surface value but only read it from what
it means in the soul what do I think
about that I think that that's don't I
wouldn't tell my students to do that I
would say we should think about the city
and speech this is the ideal city for
those who aren't getting the reference
in Plato's Republic and we should think
about the soul and why why would we
restrict ourselves and only think about
one unless
maybe his class is only focused on on
something like that so yeah here's a
great question from James what about the
desire to stay outside of the cave and
not go back near the cave and liberate
the remaining people could this be the
philosophy isolates himself from the
world and refuses to live his life in
the ordinary world and refuses his
societal function instead of opting to
focus on the realm of the forms and I
think there's probably a lot of people
who would would do that and they'd be
like okay go down then they came and
people that treat him bad and they'd be
like screw this I'm not gonna back down
in there those those ingrate SOPs I'm
not gonna get killed by them in rational
response and this is this is a an issue
of for you know quite a quite a few
things right
all those men - right so in Buddhism we
see this tension right this is where you
could say one of the big divides between
Theravada and then Miami Buddhism comes
in what a bodhisattva is a being who
could cross over it to Nirvana who you
know has become enlightened and comes
back or bastards here in the world and
takes a vow not to enter Nirvana until
all these other beings have been
liberated that's like going to back down
into the cave a big fan of who I just
did a video about why I'm a big fan of
him Cicero says a similar thing and he
criticizes Plato for this actually says
philosophers you know there's a
contemptible of life and there's an
active life and philosophers ought to be
living the active life of contemplative
and active they shouldn't be withdrawing
from society
you know that's kind of kind of
interesting I'm already a little bit
over time but I gotta get to see what I
can tackle very quickly
oh this is room time what if the truth
you find is something that you think
would make it miserable for others to
exist and that makes you not want to
tell anyone about it um then I guess you
you wouldn't want to tell anyone about
it you'd keep it to yourself right like
you know if you think about ages that's
really a premise in a number of his
stories if we actually understood the
universe I've never enjoyed anything but
of course Lovecraft characters look kind
of good all right
Klee knock out green green wolf ask the
question that's the sort of thing where
you'd want to like you know book a
tutorial session or something feelings I
would get you know that sort of
discussion Stephen what do you get out
of escaping the cave you get to be in
content with reality that's kind of nice
it has a follow up sure but why choose
reality because you want reality I mean
this is the thing if you think that is
where like you decide you know your
hierarchy of goods I'd rather just enjoy
myself I don't want to be I don't care
about contact with reality like that guy
in the matrix is who says I understand
that the stake is not a real stake but
how I want to eat some steak
oh that's kind of good one let's see oh
[Music]
so here's here's a good one
- from dis identity even if we assume
the outsides existence we have a problem
distinguishing between some
oh man man talking nonsense shouldn't
you bring a token as proof instead of
promises
well guess in order to keep him from
doing that Plato doesn't doesn't have
that in there but how would you
distinguish I'm in the the Kade you
can't distinguish between somebody who's
been outside of the cave and somebody
who's crazy but there is an outside and
so if you do get to it then you can be
like oh yeah
so that that now I get what they're
saying about people in Forbes and then
you know form of the good and all that
sort of stuff now in that depth in the
sort of physical representation fit in
philosophy right it was supposed to be
getting out of the cave and grasping the
forms there's no there's an experiential
that's fee because thinking is an
experience you know and so de Grasse
platonic for my guess would be one way
you could verify whether this is all BS
or madness or whether whether they're
onto something or not pink playdoh
he's counseling us to do that there'd be
certain prerequisites we wouldn't be
able to do that and just live any kind
of life we want but you know it's not
the sort of thing that you could like
put into your calendar okay between you
know 1:00 and 2:30 I'm gonna contemplate
the Platonic forms and verify for myself
whether the Platonic you know notion is
actually onto something or not it's not
that kind of thing it a bit of work but
you know I mean it's it's doable I guess
there's people do make that into a
project for themselves so alright I'm
gonna say thanks to everybody for all of
your questions I didn't get to everyone
but for a little bit over time and I got
I got a lot of work I got to do this
weekend unfortunately otherwise it's
stick around longer but we will be
having you know two more these full
three pop-ups one on Facebook live one
on YouTube live for February I announced
them this ahead of time to my patreon
everybody else finds out the day of and
then of course I have my AMA session and
also underwritten by my patreon
supporters that one is scheduled I
believe for the 17th of February it's on
Saturday so that's a good place to come
with with all of you know where to find
me you know if you if you want to know
more about the sort of stuff that I do
if you're interested in supporting on
patreon
I'll give the link on and they thanks
anybody who do does her for this
philosophy pop up and a nice day outside
it's almost in the 50s here in Milwaukee
he's a hopefully I'll get to enjoy some
of that hopefully you're enjoying
yourself wherever you are